exactly rolling yeah okay great so we
just realized we didn't tell the office
that we're doing this naked sushi thing
today so I thought let's just not tell
them and then it'll be a prank and then
we'll do a prank video he's seriously
getting this yeah I just got I got no I
just gotta tell it char to make sure
it's okay I know Dean's on board
Zack is on pause right sex on board I'm
on board
everybody's on board we're doing this
sushi thing today we're gonna be naked
buying sushi antibodies we didn't tell
anybody
is that okay okay cool
he was like you're gonna do it what what
it's funny so we didn't actually get the
co-ed room HR but they got to go herb
from David who sits next to HR which is
just as good so the two people maybe or
noon know they're here already
you're okay I'm gonna email Peggy tell
her about the you lunch
Eugene any any final thoughts I'm just
excited to ruin sushi for everybody you
don't stop my glass
[Music]
we are going to be covered in sushi
naked and then we're gonna surprise our
co-workers with our delicious bodies so
first what do you do
I put sushi on naked women Wow Wow
really lay this all out there for you it
seems like this practice might be
controversial
the women are willing participants we
treat them not as objects but as art
they can't touch you they can't ask you
sexual questions I feel like it is very
artistic it's beautiful like once you
see it like it just depends on the day
but sometimes there's flowers there's
banana leaves and it's really pretty and
do we need more tape for my nipples what
advice do you have for us they told me
it's better to be hairless for this we
don't have time for that do you make the
makeup a little more asian asian in
particular but I mean you're obviously
the influence is there so basically you
to put a lot of makeup on the other try
guys but I just have to show my face you
have to be quiet
so you can't really talk to them I'm not
good at keeping my mouth shut I feel
like I'll giggle a lot
I have no gauge for who can actually
physically be still in quiet I think I'm
gonna be the best
yeah I'm really energetic and I'm gonna
have a hard time staying still what's
your advice for me maybe maybe you can
do like your back side or your butt so
everything's on your butt and your box I
cuz then you're laying flat instead of
on your stomach so it's a little bit
easier that sounds like a pretty great
experience to me people eating sushi
have no butt be concerned about farting
did you think about that no I do think
those the whole thing is gonna be
torture for me because I love sushi I
love using sushi so much my body runs
really warm I feel like I'm gonna heat
it up very quickly and it would just be
baked fish I'm looking forward to being
in an art exhibit I'm really excited
about lipping the script and letting
women eat off of me can you call the
California role reversal it's like a
California roll reversal it's a
California roll my joke
what's this stuff down here this is
daikon fish should we shut it off oh
please try this to see me it's delicious
this is why I go to the gym so you can
hold sushi on naked body and really
awkward poses
it feels kind of relaxing taking a
selfie yeah it's a good idea you can
hear people outside they want this food
they hungry they think they wanted we
got a line of people at the door and
Here I am complaining about how the
sushi on my butt I think it's gonna be
very uncomfortable having my friends and
co-workers eat sushi off me I was
walking into work and I got an email on
my phone I was told that I was going to
be having sushi so I didn't do anything
for lunch because I wanted sushi I was
like yes yes I said he was coming at
noon and then it wasn't coming till 1:00
and then at one that people who started
to line up because they were starving
woman here I was like this is not
acceptable first of all I think it's
illegal you can put this in the video
I think it's fully illegal I actually
kind of dug it wasn't like you were
pulling sushi you know out of someone's
butt it was more like you were pulling
it off of there but Keith's most
attractive dude ever so he's pretty much
the quintessential human sushi fighter
Zac had a lot hair so I walked up to
Zack and then I picked off a piece that
I thought looked the best without taking
note that it was just on his crotch and
it was like oh my gosh I didn't realize
I just picked it up off your penis the
sashimi from Eugene's nether regions was
actually may have been the freshest
Eugene pops out at me we have a weird
job we have you see your naked
co-workers and a naked woman who you who
I thought was our intern I took the most
sushi from the lady because I trusted
her more
lots of people were more interested in
getting the sushi off of the real model
the nice thank my my butt sashimi wasn't
that appetizing to people it's
interesting how people judge the sushi
by the platter I mean I think the worst
part was not being able to eat and I was
very patient and he said not eat I did
not eat and then I looked over and then
Eugene ate all our sushi
that's I will say I might try
going home stripping naked putting pizza
on my naked body eating off myself I do
it with pizza oh my man Janet would like
roasted veggies lobster ravioli oh damn
I felt like an art exhibit I really did
Keith that's ours no bro it's
everybody's do you think it was a good
prank yeah
[Applause]